hi sorry about the delay my name is
Jessica Ford and I work with project
Jupiter and I would like to encourage
you all first of all to please
contribute a project Jupiter but I'm
actually here to talk about other
libraries that are in the PI data open
source data science community and about
party planning and about why you should
basically never do your seating
assignments by hand so if you're like me
you like a casual party you know people
sitting around the table maybe some
chips maybe some dip you know very very
informal gatherings and those are
typically the parties I like to organize
but unfortunately most parties aren't
necessarily all like that there are
formal seating arrangements there's
caterers there's all these sorts of
things you have to worry about and if
you're a bridesmaid like me sometimes
you tend to find that very frustrating
so you end up having to deal with lots
of minutiae and details and out of the
data scientist we don't necessarily want
to deal with that and so we would like
to figure out a way to make this a
little more optimal so if I'm going to
drive home one message to you all don't
do your seating arrangements by hand
again I'm just going to say one more
time don't do your seating arrangements
by hand so there are various tools
developed by operations research
computer science mathematics called
optimization methods and with these
optimization methods you can to also
solve the dreaded seating assignment
problem so when we're going to talk
about some math here set partitioning
divides a set of integers in this case
maybe people into K subsets
all right so the K subsets might be your
K tables and in except partitioning each
integer must be included now if we want
to actually exclude an integer just
because it's too inconvenient to find a
table for them to sit in we would call
this set packing and when K equals 2 you
can use your trusty old dynamic
programming from your algorithms text
look to solve the problem but if K is
greater than two then you get to do some
interesting research on better methods
for scalability and optimization so
there are a number of open source
optimization libraries out there that
can handle solving various optimization
problems and they often require the user
to define the problem in some sort of
mathematical format all right so one of
these kinds of problems is a linear
program so this optimizes a linear
functions subject to some sort of
constraint and the pulp library which is
a Python linear programming library one
of many has a really nice tutorial on
seating assignments which has been
written by Stuart Mitchell which defines
it as a linear problem which is a within
which some variables are integers which
is also known as a mixed integer linear
problem so in this case we have we want
to minimize the total amount of
unhappiness at each table and we want to
make sure that each table assigns
someone and that everybody ends up in a
table so now it's time for us to plan
our party so I'm going to be planning a
party for the managers of hen Ron and
this is a thanks to the Freedom of
Information Act we get an email from
individuals and Ron mostly management
this is a subset of about 150
individuals which has been published by
the Federal Energy Regulatory Commission
it's about 500 thousand emails and
thanks to a bunch of researchers such as
guro and my colleague Steven to we're
able to get this at a nice neat format
if you want to look for the data itself
I just have the link below and there are
other ways of solving this problem the
Megan bellows and JD Luke Peterson did a
really nice job of actually of defining
the happiness metric as actually a a
distance between individuals
in which if people know each other we
give them a score of 1 if people don't
know each other we give them a score of
0 and if they're you know like partners
or close family like month like parents
and children or something like that then
we give them a score of 50 and then we
subject them to a number of additional
constraints so to break down the math in
here for each guests pair J and K we
have an adjacency matrix that represents
the relationship between them and as I
said we give them a score of 0 if they
don't know each other 1 if they do and
50 if they're very close if just guess J
and K are at the same table then the
table gets the score from this adjacency
matrix and we want to be able to sub to
maximize the score of all these tables
subject to every guest being seated no
table has more assignments than the
number of seats and each guest much no
be other guests in their table now I'm
going to take a minute to set up my
other computer which has a toy demo
you hold in your machine against our
external close it see
can you see that okay me let's go huntin
okay
just gonna try to increase in size let's
kick you guys let me know if you guys
can read it okay let's see
this is big enough can you guys read it
all yeah okay this is a live mic sorry
about that
okay so again as I said let's imagine
115 managers at Enron are having a party
and thanks to FOIA we can guess their
social connections through their email
so I've imported in a bunch of typical
data science libraries some of the ones
you might not be the one you might not
be familiar with is pulp pulp is a
library for linear programming and I'm
just borrowing I modify some code that
Stephen too has written to process the
pickle's results of the data set of 115
managers and in here I'm just saying if
the if the person is talking about
themselves then we're not we're gonna
assume they don't note with himself and
if they do know them cell if they email
someone then both the sender and
receiver pair and the receiver sender
pair in this matrix our marked is true
right so we just have a simple boolean
we're kind of assuming that no one here
is like close family or something like
that
okay so I'm just gonna plot this and
this is what the matrix looks like but
you know given the fact that these
methods can be pretty demanding
computationally I'm going to be using a
subset of this data and I'm just going
to be slightly modifying the tutorial
from Stuart Mitchell at pulp which is an
open source library for linear
programming and so I have now taken the
first 25 people by their ID and I've
made it into a data frame and I'm just
going to now look for individuals in
that 25 people under which they at least
know one person right they know one
other person just to simplify the
problem and to make sure we are getting
people at the party you know
each other so when we when we take that
out then we can plot the number of
connections each person has right so six
is the social butterfly six notes
everybody and twenty-one it was only one
other person most other people know
about two or three people so there are
now 16 individuals which is a nice
number to work with for simplicity and
I'm just going to divide them into four
tables of four and I'm gonna take a
different distance metrics for two from
Mitchell's tutorial and I'm gonna use
instead the Bellas and Peterson metric
which is the happiness of the table as
defined as the number of social
connections within that table so I'm
just taking the table and I'm summing up
the number of throughs and I'm dividing
it by two because the matrix is
symmetric so now I've enumerated the
possible tables in here right so this is
4 choose 4 and there are all mo possible
tables and then I'm now defining the
guests as the IDS and then I've just
picked the simpler of the optimization
problems and these two by using Stuart
Mitchell so I want to be able to
maximize the happiness quotient which
you see as the seating model defined and
I'm saying that that the table can be if
a table has end up being used in this
optimization we have marked it as 1 as
opposed to 0 and we're specifying that
the maximum number of tables in here is
4 and we want to make sure that there's
only there is a each guest is that
seated at one and only one table and now
we just run solve and we're just now
appending the list of tables that are an
idiot being chosen and this runs really
really fast because there's actually not
that many option
so if we scroll down these are the
assignments we end up getting so these
are the four tables these are the four
individuals made four groups of four
that ended up being chosen and now we
can just plot them all right so tables
I'm using Python numbering just because
this is a Python party so we're gonna
start at zero and table zero has three
social connections so person number four
knows one person person number twelve
knows number twenty-four person sixteen
also knows person number twenty-four and
person number twenty-four knows two
people right so with network X I can
just visualize this network right so so
two people only know one person and two
people no to people and then table one
has four social connections right so
person number six is the social
butterfly who knows everybody person
number five knows two people and person
number ninety knows no to people and
person number twenty-one only knows
person number six and then similarly we
have two pairs of two who know each
other but they don't know they don't
know the other pairs and then we have a
similar situation as table 1 and table 3
so I've used an open-source data set to
come up with a Jason C matrix but it's
actually pretty easy to use name your
favorite social network API to come up
with your list of friends and their
social connections and to figure out how
to define who knows whom among the
people you know and then with local
knowledge I'm sure you can figure out
who this sort of close relations are and
who wants to be city seated with each
other and again these matrices are
symmetric so hopefully collecting this
data should be a little bit easier now
as due to time constraints optimization
methods can take time to solve and we're
only using 16 users right so this is not
gonna take too much time I could have
rerun the whole thing from scratch in a
matter of seconds so it's it's really
not that much really choosing four out
of over eighteen hundred possibilities
so that that's generally pretty easy to
work with but if you're actually really
planning your own party and say you have
a couple hundred people right then you
might have a lot more options to go
through in in the example from the
Bellas and Peterson paper the model had
to run for 36 hours
but luckily the solution that they ended
up working with was pretty happy with
the mother-in-law of the bride and I
mean the mother of the bride and with
the rest of the party so hopefully
that's pretty promising for you all so
now some other avenues for planning
another way of solving these kinds of
problems is a simulated annealing and
that's another popular method for
optimization which uses randomization is
to take large steps in a search space
earlier in the period of searching and
then slows down the search period over
time Wikipedia provides a really nice
gift slow showing this process and this
is used in luke plants web app fire by
way of
Harry Gio's seminal library so I'm just
gonna pull that I'm actually I'm I don't
think I could pull up the web give me a
minute I'm gonna try to pull it up so
Luke plants library ends up actually
using the same metric we've defined as
an adjacency matrix matrix to social to
define social connections but the main
difference is that it uses simulated
annealing to solve the problem and I was
actually able to install it rather fine
it uses uses a Python web app give me a
minute
about this
see
we got this
this weekend I'm having problems
okay so as you can see this is a web app
for seeding planning that I've bitbucket
let's see
and it lets you set up the social
connections from scratch and then run
simulated annealing to solve this is
something you might want to give to
someone else who may not necessarily be
able to collect the data on their own
but is another really interesting option
available in the open-source community
besides this this website web app and a
party website you can also automate
party planning with additional api is to
Leo's blog has provided a really great
introduction to their API with scripts
to manage a guest list so if you go to
their blog there's a really nice and for
information about how to send out
notifications how to collect RSVPs and
two measures who's coming who has an RV
RSVPs things like that but I think the
thing I would like you all to take away
is that organization libraries are
really great for decision making I think
that personally as a data scientist
decision-making is often the thing that
we end up being most helpful to our
peers so optimization is a really great
way of aiding and decision making
because it allows us to define a metric
of measurement for cost or reward that
we can compare across different options
and it also allows us to define the
screen strengths of a problem that might
be important which helps us have a good
conversation with members of our team or
other researchers we work with and many
libraries are open source I've used pulp
in this example but jump jl is a julia
library that has gotten good reviews pi
o mo is another Python library that is a
optimization library and optimization
has been used
for decades and industry it's used in
scheduling it's used in logistics and
conceivably you can also use it for
setting up seating arrangements so i
really suggest that you all try out
using an open-source optimization
library it's a great tool to add to your
toolkit and hopefully it'll take some of
the stress off your next party so they
might I think they might actually add
some add some constraints to smooth the
problem I know that in the fellows in
Petersons paper they add additional
constraints to linearize the problem so
that might be the way that they deal
with it
because I think they're using they're
using the problem set up as defined by
thousands and Peter's in so hopefully
that helps
yeah I'll put them online I'm trying to
clean this up something nice um just as
a plug I'll be more than happy to put
this up as like a finder binder is one
of our projects that is really really
great that allows you to share notebooks
and we'll give you my environment set up
so I can totally put that together and
put that online um so see that in the
future
[Applause]